my name is john schultz and as i said
i'm here to speak about canvas in
node.js
real briefly about me i'm currently at
include in dc it's a web consultant
company uh design firm but doing mostly
web consulting before that i was at omni
ti which is also another
web consulting company
while at omni fti we released a
monitoring service called circonus and i
did a lot of work with charting there
that's part of where some of the stuff
came from and you can find me on twitter
at jfs iii
so why are we doing canvas on node um
it's to replace either this script tag
which is loading your library and then
instantiating it
or an iframe
with image source equals
and
that still normally gets you two but why
are you doing canvas in node and the
best way is to give you a use case so we
had made some canvas-based charts for a
customer and they really liked them and
they wanted to put the charts in their
wiki
canvas-based charts need a browser or a
document an iframe is a good way to do
that
you know just you would link to whatever
normal content is and put you know
chrome equals false or something along
those lines unframed problem is wikis
don't allow iframes or most don't
so i really really want to make this
work i mean it seemed like a completely
valid use case to take these charts we
had worked on and get them to work at
their company and it was a compliment
they liked our stuff enough that they
wanted to share these items within the
company so i did a little looking and i
did find a project called rhinocanvas
but
it is it looks dead in the water i
haven't seen any activity since i was
six
so i made a request on twitter just some
of the people i could think about
basically you get what are you talking
about it's image why are you doing an
image on the server or specifically why
are you doing canvas which is clearly a
browser item on the server
i did talk to some other people and
cairo was mentioned cairo does
svg png
pdf generation does a lot of stuff it's
got hooks for php perl a whole lot of
other languages so i thought that if i
had the wherewithal i could just
re-implement the canvas api and see but
that wasn't
the most exciting thing to me
the good news is i'm serious three days
after i figured out that i would use
canvas i mean uh cairo tj has some post
about how he's almost done with node
canvas
so thankfully
um a couple weeks after that learn boost
and tj released node canvas
and does exactly what i was trying to do
and it's canvas api compatible so you
get all the stuff you expect you get
move to line two stroke fill fill
rectangle
everything you expect out of a canvas
instance and it gives you a couple other
items which um two which are really
important one of which is really
important to me create png stream and to
buffer
so i'm going through a couple examples
um this example is a little bit trimmed
down from the one that's on the new
canvas site
and
notice here i mean i made a note in the
comments the only difference between a
typical canvas script is that one have
to require canvas and then really your
instantiation
that instead of saying canvas equals
document create new canvas canvas.height
equals canvas.with equals you just pass
the height and width and the constructor
from there on you write create canvas
like you normally would um here i'm
doing two data url which is standard
method
and that gives you you know big data uri
which would produce woot
here's gradients
and again the only two items that
the change here require canvas and new
canvas
everything else is the same this is the
image that it generates
is that a typo that you left off at
night
oh yeah yeah i was doing some editing
yeah it's not that magical um i was
changing the plane around size sorry
about that yeah it's definitely a typo
um a graph or whatever a sparkline
similar item this is all what you would
do in canvas that you were doing on the
client side
so
that gets me close um it means it's
possible for me to write canvas in node
the real issue is though for me
i can't i still can't use flot
over on the server side
um
i don't want to spend my time writing a
charting library there's already one out
there that works in particular the
customer liked our graphs we had made
some new data visualizations we had done
you know customizing of the colors
whatever i didn't feel like doing that
work again
so um flot uses jquery jquery uses the
dom so you have to find a way to get the
dom onto the server
and that thanks to uh elijah can be in
js dom is possible
js dom which i don't know if you saw
elijah's talk this morning but it's a
way to get the dom it's a common jazz
implementation of the dom
uh so
why why exactly the dom before so the
way jquery i'm sorry go ahead so the way
we did it uh we run plot
on the server side and
we basically bootstrapped a couple
jquery functions
and then the only problem is that for
some reason flawed uses dom for the
labels
but there's a project that implements
labels in camera correct then you don't
need the json i'd love to get that
actually was talking to tj about it i
was trying to add a project called
drawback so what it does is
um
basically be able to share the same code
uh in the client and the server as far
as what's actually doing the rendering
of the chart
and then for the server side adds hooks
so for example if you want to get a
preview of the chart it's going to
execute the same code and also load
additional plugins like for example
rendering the text in the canvas gotcha
so we can go into that afterwards but
what gamma was saying was that they have
done some work to make to where you
don't even need jsdom to have jquery run
i did like i said i was talking to tj
about it and i couldn't get a hold of
that so i found you'll see in a minute
here a way that while it does require
loading some additional stuff it was
also the minimum amount of work that was
required for me
so jsdom is incredible
and
it currently gives you dom level one and
two browser support
and with that dom i can now get jquery
to run on the server
here's an example it's the same same
thing that elijah had this morning just
get jsdom in this particular case you're
loading nodejs.org
and then going to inject jquery i made a
note that is production jquery
when it's ready it runs jquery against
that content and counts the number of
anchors number of links that are there
so you can do screen scraping in this
example at js dom
so patching flop was really simple
because that canvas api is api
compatible all i really had to do and
flock was just go to the place where
that canvas was created
and make a change to it um just did a
branching there was
one other thing which is that flat in
particular wants a width and a height
which it grabs from the dom element so
since there wasn't a width and height or
jquery wasn't able to determine those i
made it i gave it the config option of
giving it a width and a height
so technically i'd add a couple more
lines however that that's a complaint
that's common in flot is that i want to
tell you how
the dimensions of this image perhaps
you've got a div or something that is
off screen at the moment so if it's
hidden initially flat would see that as
zero zero and wouldn't render it anyway
so you can't pre-render so that's
something that's coming in a newer
version of flot it's i needed it in
particular for this but eventually that
means it's one less item you'd have to
patch
i do have the patch this is from o6 i've
got that available as a guest did you
push that back
i haven't made those conventions i did
post the the patches that are available
and i worked with them um when we did
the github fork
so i've been having discussions with
it's not committed yet and that's
actually one of the things i'm trying to
i'll get committed in there
so i definitely that would be the ideals
to not have to patch anything just get
it committed because it really it's
completely compatible i can run a client
side or server side it's fine
so here's an example
so i've got a domain jso.de which is
where i play with node stuff
and
so this example let's see if i've got it
all right so this is basically just
taking a js dom example um
and converting it or whatever adding a
couple things in
so in this example require js dom give
it a
base dom to work with
again production jquery code my patched
flaw
and then here's one of the there's two
plugins that um as gamma was saying the
only real remaining challenge with flot
is that it renders labels in absolutely
positioned divs so they're not a part of
the canvas and when you go to do actions
like two data url or whatever you now
don't have them so all you would have is
a canvas with lines and fills but
nothing to say the current value is 50
or this is pertaining to cpu usage or
whatever so there's existing canvas
plugins i mean um flop plugins to get
text in this is a totally unpatched
flot plug-in
actually
i guess i'll get to it later but that
will be going away the need for that is
going away soon
and then when it's ready
this is just generating data i would
have to do this if i were showing you
how to use flot just make some random
data the only things that are of any
real
change are the height and width
that i mentioned earlier
and for that particular plugin it takes
a canvas text argument to grid
give it some information about how what
the uh
font is to be
and then i set clickable and hoverable
to false those are again normal flat
options there's no need to apply any
sort of listeners since i'm going to be
returning a static image
and after that
a couple aliases here just so that i
don't have to write window.jquery or
window.dollar in my code
create a shim div
this signature right here plot equals
plot div data and options that's a
completely standard flock haul
getcanvas is a normal flop method
here i'm getting the
node canvas back which has those
additional methods i happen to define
where i want to do this output and then
you create a right stream um more
importantly create a png stream and then
as it gets data right to that
that created
jsdom.png which
is back
here um
i think i can do
and so oh and by the way
so that's what was actually being
written out
so going a little bit deeper
i've got just node json od slash flot
which is just a way again for me to
experiment with stuff
i want to be able to do image source
equals something and
get data back so
you can on this particular whatever
instance i have i can actually pass
parameters in via the query string
probably not what you want to do in
production but it's possible so in this
case i can give it a json object or just
options or just data
so if you give it
a list of options
that'll give us
right
i have an issue with that occasionally
where those don't get there but that is
live data
so i do use one dom in that earlier
example i was always doing a choir
setting up nfd dom writing to it
there's really no need to do that so
that's a jsnod flats and express app so
what i do is when i create the service
created i do this real basic script
injection where
script injection where
same things you saw earlier
i just
load up
the patched flot
and the text um plug-in that i need just
to have those there and that does it one
time i then assign
window.canvas to that canvas that uh
node canvas item and same thing i was
doing before global.jquery equals
window.dollar so i can use those later
on in the script so the idea there is
that i have one dom that and i think i
go to next that when i'm actually
writing the image back all i ever do is
create a jquery item and it's always
dealing with that one document so i'm
not
making multiple documents or making a
new one each time because it just seemed
wasteful and it also happens to work
here
so this is render flaw image which is
what is used to render that um
jsnode slash flot
i happen to get some data create data
like you saw before i'm just getting rid
of that
placeholder equals jquery i don't even
actually in this example i don't even
throw it a div this seems to be enough
to allow it to work
again the standard
plot uh or fl call signature node canvas
just to remind me that i've got
a enhanced api
and now i make two buffer which is what
gives you this that binary image and
then i just in my response i give that
image back
and i'm really i haven't done enough
testing to determine what effect
placeholder has but i actually decided
just to delete placeholder because
it couldn't hurt i don't know it's
working it might clean memory up for me
i haven't been able to put this thing
under enough load to determine if that
has any effect or not
so wrapping up um
advantages
big thing image works everywhere i
explained we had people that wanted a
wiki i couldn't do an iframe on that um
you've got older
browsers or even current browsers that
don't support canvas mobile is another
one so or if it's in either a older or
just lower powered i guess through age
or
form factor
they might not have support for canvas
everything's got support for image most
things you care about
code reuse and this was key with me we
had already done work into getting these
charts to look the way that i wanted
and
i wanted to quickly get something up
that would allow us to use this for this
client
um
so that was key for me
performance
images less burden
again i mentioned lower power devices
instead of me giving a data structure to
the device having the device constructed
and render it i'm just giving binary
image data back so there's definitely a
performance gain on that
for some items
privacy is huge
in the monitoring service i was
mentioning with some people that just
wanted they wanted to share their charts
but they wanted to show the relative
change or relevant effect they didn't
want to show
actual membership database queries
whatever it was and if i was just giving
a json data structure back you can see
that in the net request
it's possible to obfuscate it but you're
one way or another you're going to get
it it's just script that's coming across
here i can make all the changes i want
on the server determine what i want the
person to see and return a completely
opaque image or
as opaque as i want it to be image back
to the client
caching now that you've got a
standard http request you can cache it
like you would anything else
let's say you've got something like
sales and you know that if i'm given a
start and end date and they're both in
the past new sales aren't going to have
occurred put a far futures header on it
and you can cache it as aggressively as
you would anything else or as you would
that type of data elsewhere
on a side note i mean if you've tried to
ever cache xhr if you've ever dealt with
a 304 of an xhr it's really problematic
um so 304 says the data hasn't changed
ask the server can you give me the data
the server says use what you have the
xhr object gives you back empty
there's no way to get the data that you
did have before so when you try to do
the right thing using xhr if you give a
three or four back
it's it's uh debilitating or it's really
depressing that you can't use that so
this allows me to get around that as
well
text um one of the benefits i guess of
having a single platform you know what
you have installed on your server so you
can use a certain font
disadvantages i think the first one
being i'm now bringing load from a
client back you know the nodes are going
from a node
back to the hub so you are taking on
some burden but i think you can offset
that by some of the things i mentioned
caching and etc it's an image
a lot of fun stuff can be done in canvas
mouse over tool tips expand zoom i can't
do any of that with an image so and
clearly that's gone
and it's another piece of technology in
your infrastructure you might not be
using node already
again that's not too terrible i mean you
can make a request that goes to a
certain port or a certain url and just
send that through so it's only being run
that only that little bit's being run by
node you probably have your own image
server any way that's doing something
similar or if you're doing service item
generation you'd already have that
memory
as i said i haven't dealt with um enough
to know i'm not seeing it but i know
there's been there was some question
from elijah if i was running into it
when i showed him what i did he said i
should be fine but
this is not thoroughly vetted so i'm not
exactly sure what people would run into
with it
i don't know if any other i said this
hasn't been i didn't get a chance to
implement this at the
monitoring company at sarcones
so i'm not quite sure
basic questions can't you do this with
gd or image magic you can but i wanted
the same charts that i already had
i like the client side charting
libraries a lot better i think there's a
lot more development actually going on
in that
so it's a lot more a lot there's a lot
more for me to choose from
and what i like is if i find something i
like i can just do basically a patch
like i showed you before go find where
it creates canvas change that little bit
out and
theoretically that's it or do a little
bit more digging but
it's really not that much work to get a
client-side library to work on the
server side
uh sorry performance i've mentioned
not really sure some flat specific items
actually didn't realize until yesterday
that flot 07 is out came out about a
month ago so i actually did a patch um
with the internet issues today i
couldn't make my changes over but
it's a similar patch it's really simple
just the line number's changing enough
that i couldn't apply the same one
flat 08 so the version that's in sbn
right now is doing all the rendering or
at least
doing the label rendering in text so you
don't even need that plug-in i don't
they're the tick label
rendering and text i don't think they
have the labels down yet but that's
definitely where they're moving so you
would just specify
font size fill etcetera and options and
that would be completely standard which
means the need for that plug-in is gone
elijah mentioned node flot i'm pretty
sure he's talking about me there isn't a
node flop project
i don't know if there really should be
ideally i just commit the stuff back
it's a patch file i'm not trying to fork
maintain any of this stuff
so hopefully i will submit these if for
whatever reason i can't get them worked
in um i'll make a project which is just
gonna be a patch file right now just got
them up as guests
and that's it does anybody have any
questions
i haven't no i haven't sorry the
question was have i run rafael js i have
not um ralph
exactly so raspberry ailes svg which
means that now i did hear during rocks
rap and there's that i did hear raphael
shout it out so i believe it exists um
somebody should be able to do the same
thing
because cairo like i said also has svg
support so if somebody was similarly
motivated or if node raphael doesn't do
we think it does you should be able to
do that
any other questions
the question was is there a server-side
webgl
there's a couple is the answer from
gamma
there's uh one that involves opengl
directly
and then there's one that's in
so he said there's a couple that's right
i hadn't seen the one
okay thank you for your time
you